[Música]
hola bienvenidos a migrantes el programa
semanal de france 24 sobre el éxodo los
saluda juliet riaño
[Música]
la toma relámpago del grupo talibán en
afganistán dejó en el medio a miles de
civiles que esperan huir del país en
busca de seguridad los vecinos irán
pakistán y turquía se preparen ante una
eventual llegada masiva de refugiados
mientras el gobierno turco blinda sus
fronteras para detener el paso le
advierte a europa que no está dispuesto
a hacer un almacén de refugiados
grecia por su parte insiste en que
tampoco será la puerta de entrada a
europa y pide cooperación a la unión
europea para gestionar los flujos
migratorios veamos algunas de las
historias de los afganos que están en
tránsito
por estas montañas en la frontera entre
irán y turquía cruzan los afganos que
huyen del grupo talibán en el camino
algunas prendas de ropa y botellas
delatan su paso
viajan en grupo la mayoría son jóvenes y
adolescentes
y todo va a empeorar en afganistán somos
jóvenes que tendríamos que ir a la
escuela me encantaría poder ir a la
escuela oa la mezquita porque no fui a
una escuela porque no pude encontrar una
mi vida se acabó y solo tengo 19 años
tratan de no llamar la atención de las
autoridades turcas y se escabullan cerca
del muro que el país construye en la
frontera con irán
armand tiene sólo 17 años y este es su
segundo intento por quedarse en turquía
en la primera oportunidad las
autoridades turcas lo obligaron a
retornar a afganistán
nos arrestan y nos envían de regreso
dicen no tienes identificación viniste
legalmente hay una guerra en mi país si
no hubiera una guerra en mi país no
habría venido
en otra zona de la frontera este grupo
de afganos de cierto del ejército y
huyeron del país por el avance talibán
vinimos por el talibán y el estado
islámico no hay trabajo en afganistán
hay guerra y la policía no nos permite
cruzar la frontera que hace este punto
llevan 11 días en el camino y la opción
nunca ha sido regresar con un perro
siddiqui de adenina salimos por
necesidad el talibán ha atacado a
nuestro país y ahora lo controlan
esperamos que el gobierno turco nos
aceptó es un pedido que puede que no se
cumpla turquía no está dispuesta a
repetir la historia de 2015 cuando una
multitud de migrantes sirios rusos su
frontera y ahora refuerza sus pasos con
una barrera física que espera levantar a
lo largo de los casi 300 kilómetros del
límite con irán unos 60 de ellos ya
están en pie y desde el exilio
refugiados afganos temen por la suerte
de sus familiares que permanecen en el
país al interior casi 400.000 personas
fueron desplazadas de sus hogares por la
violencia desde principios de año una
situación que ahora se agudiza tras la
toma del poder por parte del grupo
talibán los refugiados piden ayuda a los
países del mundo para lograr
para sus seres queridos
sia y su familia lograron refugio en
alemania desde hace cuatro años tras
salir de afganistán
ahora bien con preocupación lo que pasa
en su país a través de las noticias la
toma del poder por parte del talibán
preocupa a este hombre que huyó tras
recibir amenazas por su trabajo en
afganistán lideraba programas de
democratización proyectos juveniles y
promovía los derechos de las mujeres
luchamos por todo por todas estas leyes
y políticas reformistas y ahora estamos
nuevamente en el nivel cero
wi-fi entonces me preguntas cómo me
siento realmente muy triste frustrado
perdí la esperanza y no es el único
ningún su esposa y su hija están
preocupadas por sus amigas y familiares
creo que no puedo ayudarla si eso me
molesta mucho
pero trato de hablar con ellas y
averiguar si siguen con vida ya que eso
es lo mínimo que puedo hacer
además les repito cada vez que no deben
arriesgarse ni provocar a la gente
como valer culpa al expresidente es rafa
ni por la crisis si se muestra escéptico
a las promesas del talibán
y en moscú encontramos a este órgano
huyó de su país pues temía que su vida
corriera peligro por el avance del grupo
pero lo hizo solo ahora no sabe cómo
evacuar a su esposa su hija de 10 meses
y sus dos hermanas
pasó varias noches sin poder dormir
todos los días pienso en mi familia y
estoy tratando de encontrar la manera de
sacarla de allí porque son cuatro
mujeres viviendo solas por goldman
aunque wenger
y como lo vivimos antes el talibán no
permitirá que las mujeres salgan sin
hombres captaban del negro la women
without anime en este grupo de
estudiantes afganos logró salir del país
a bordo del último vuelo antes del
cierre del aeropuerto de kabul lograron
llegar a india pero evidenciaron el caos
o mi deber
sólo el miedo porque la gente no sabe lo
que va a pasar en el futuro no saben
nada
es como si no entendiera si van a tener
comida dinero agua suministros médicos
si van a poder cubrir sus necesidades
básicas que sus preocupados
india es hogar de miles de refugiados
afganos muchos de ellos viven en
asentamientos en nueva delhi
acnur estima que hay 26 millones de
refugiados afganos en el mundo entre los
principales países receptores están
pakistán con 14 millones de acogidos e
irán con 780 mil activistas piden a los
gobiernos que no limiten el número de
refugiados afganos en sus países y
algunas naciones ya han anunciado planes
para recibirlos
hasta aquí inmigrantes de france 24 los
invitamos a comentar en nuestras redes
sociales con el hashtag migrantes f24
sigan con más información en france 24 y
france 24 puntocom
[Música]